today I'm going to talk about some
things you can do on the web that you
may or not may know we're possible the
first thing I want to talk about is the
speech API who of you knew that the
browser could talk well maybe I should
just go to the bar and have a drink but
let's see if I have some audio yeah geez
did you know the bride's I could talk
kirlyam the web speech API converts text
as spoken words you can even choose my
voice since I'm a female cat I'll be
talking with a female voice meow
so should I continue or should I just
let my cat do all the talking the cat
too bad you will have to do with me I'm
sorry but yeah the browser can talk and
it's not really that difficult to make
the browser talk most modern browsers
have started implementing the speech API
with modern browsers I mean Firefox
Chrome sometimes edge Safari is
considered a browser but not necessarily
a modern browser but let's see how we
can make the browser talk the first
thing you need is a speech synthesizer
which you can find under your window
object I just put it under sins because
send this much harder to type then we
know that speech synthesis I'm gonna
need this further in the examples once
we have that synthesizer we need to
create create a speech synthesis
utterance which is a very difficult word
and it just means that you create an
object which contains the text you want
your browser to to talk or just do we
say out loud and then some
characteristics of how to pronounce the
words so in this instance I'm just
creating a new address with the text hi
everybody
and once we have that you pterence we
just use your since we saw earlier say
that speak and give that you pterence
and that's basically all you need to do
hi everybody
to make your browser talk but as you've
heard this was hi everybody
a low male voice while my cat is a
female cat so that's not exactly either
as old I was after
so the user ins does not only contain
the text he wanted we want your browser
to talk or to say but it also contains
McCarrick characteristics like the voice
I like Fiona's voice is there Fiona in
the room
no too bad I like to be honest voice as
the voice for my cat
of course my cat is very small so I just
increase the pitch a bit so it has a
higher voice and my cat is very lazy so
I just decrease the rate a bit so it
talks a bit slower
most of them my belgian number i don't
know if you noticed but we talk slower
in the movie so when you just pass along
these these options no this is better
don't you think
sounds more like a cat to me so let's
recap you need your synthesizer you need
a user ins which is hi everybody
and then yeah you choose a voice you use
your uterus you created to set that
voice and then some other parameters
like the pitch or the rate and just let
your synthesizer talk that's it
the second thing is the speech
recognition API who have you ever heard
of the speech recognition API wow you're
really like you know everything that's
cool but yeah your browser can recognize
your speech or the stuff you say so
let's hope it works because live demos
hi everybody it does not work oh just
reload just for fun hi everybody
yeah nice so in the green bubble you see
the stuff I just said hi everybody I
could have said any other thing but
since I talked with a little bit of an
accent and my English is not perfect I
try to keep it as simple as possible but
the browser once I click the button
started listening to what I was saying
and then it started analyzing every word
that I said and in the end it returned
that I said hi everybody it is important
to note that you need Internet
for this API to work that's why I have
my phone here it's a hotspot so I have
some internet because the magic doesn't
happen in the browser is really just
chrome chrome only Chrome which sends
the things you say to a server there's
some magic stuff and then sends a
response back so let's see how we can do
this the first thing you do is make a
new speech recognition instance once you
have that you can set some parameters
like I want to start recognizing you as
English I don't want the intermediate
results and then what to do when you get
a result or what to do when you get an
error back and that's basically it so
when you get a result back you will get
an object which contains the thing you
said or what the Google servers think
you said and also you get a percentage
of how sure it is that it's got cutted
right but you said that it understood
you perfectly so on the next one is a
geolocation API I think you all have
seen these websites these days that ask
you like can I get your permission to
know where you are especially news
websites and other useless websites it's
done with the geolocation API so let's
let's see if it can find out where I am
Amsterdam that's right I think so the
browser just figured out that I am in
Amsterdam and we're more or less in that
building called Korea so that's quite
accurate actually so the browser just
figured out that I'm more or less in the
vicinity of that point which a bit it's
a bit spooky it's good to know that you
will have to give your permission to a
website for them to be able to get your
location not just any website can go and
ask your ask your location but once
you've given the permission you can do
stuff like this and you can do this with
geolocation that get current position
and that returns some coordinates now I
don't know about you but coordinates and
I really know what I mean because it's a
longitudinal latitude and it's just a
bunch of numbers so I use a Google Maps
API you can use any
the API but the Google Maps API is easy
to convert these coordinates to a place
that's readable by me like the locality
which is Amsterdam and looks like my cat
figured out how to send notifications
because you can do that in a browser
these days and you can do that using the
notifications API
sorry notifications pretty easy and you
can do it like this first off again if
you ask for permission so you cannot
just start sending notifications to
everybody but once you've given that
notification all you need to do is
create a new notification and send along
some text like a title or a body or a
cat picture as an icon because get
pictures you always need cat pictures
and you get something like this and this
is a native notification or as X but if
you're using Windows or Linux it will be
the native notification of your
operating system so it's nice to know
that you can really use some native
features of your of your operating
system from the browser you can also add
click events to this notification so
when I would have clicked on that
notification I could have opened a
website or gone to a certain page or
done a certain action by just adding a
click event handler to that notification
we created earlier the next one are push
notifications or push notifications just
this a bit in team does anybody does
anybody know the difference between a
regular notification and a push
notification you're not going to answer
anyway but I will explain for you it's
nice to know that there's some people
who already know it if I click this
button we see notification and it's it
kind of looks the same as the previous
ones but it's important to know that
this notification was not sent from the
front end of my website my JavaScript
but came from a push server and was
pushed to the front end we were just
listening for a push event and then one
meeting once we got that event we showed
the notification it has some benefits
like if I would just close this window
and we would not be browsing my website
but something would have happened and my
server would decide
or not oh there it is dead I wanted to
show a notification you can still show
notifications from even though I'm not
really visiting that website anymore
which is kind of black magic so that's
that's one of the the main advantages of
push notifications and how they're
implemented in the browser so let's see
if we can get this running again all
right you start listening for a notified
notification event you first need to
register a service worker and a service
worker is basically just an external
worker which can intercept Network
requests or you can cache stuff with it
or you can just start listening for push
push offense so you just check if it's
available in your browser once it has
its available you just register this
service worker dulces file and once
that's registered you have access to the
push man push manager so you can create
a subscription send a subscription to
your servers so that your server know is
that this ID which you just created is
your user so you will only get the right
messages for your user and once you've
done this you can start listening for a
push event this is a lot I'm just going
to skip to it because it's a half code
but it's just a basic idea of how it
works once we get a push events you can
just do self at registration dot show
notification and show a title of a body
you can also I've hard coded this title
and body in this example but you can
just get them from the push message that
was sent from the server instead of
hard-coding them so you can get some
dynamic push message but that's about
everything you need to do to show push
mess push messages even if the user is
not on your website as long as a browser
it's not completely shut down the next
one is a battery manager API which is a
bit creepy because why would a browser
need access to the data of your battery
it's a funny story but as you can see my
battery is charging and F 86% of battery
which is correct
now if I would unplug my power cord it
doesn't do anything because of live
demos so let's just refresh this page
and try again okay yeah it advanced
while I was not clicking my stuff so the
thing I wanted to demonstrate with this
is it can listen to changes in the state
of your battery or state changes in a
state of if you are charging or not and
that's done by the push manager API the
Belle woman's API sorry and the first
thing you need to do is navigated up get
battery and then it will return a
battery object which contains a few
things like it's your is your device
charging or not or is what is the level
of your of your battery in my instance
it was 86 percent I think how long will
it take to charge and how long will it
take the battery to be completely
discharged but you can also start
listening for changes in these in this
data like you can add some event
listeners and then when the level
changes or when the charging change you
can advise advance to the next slide if
your demos would work which they didn't
so yeah the next one is the media
recorder API has anybody ever played
with this before few hands I'm happy
there's not too many hands because I
really like this one and what it does is
it records some media like you would
expect so let's record some media hi
everybody
everybody so I just created a movie
right in my browser without some special
back-end services or anything I just
started recording the camera feed and my
microphone feed and came up with this
movie that we can replay if we want to
because it's super interesting once
again so I can drink
hi everybody so yeah I just recreated it
recorded a video in my browser using the
media recorder API and to do this you
need to combine a few API so actually
the first thing you need to do is get
access to your microphone and to your
webcam so we use getusermedia for this
navigate about media media devices don't
get user media this used to be just
under navigator and but they moved it to
under to be under media devices and it
now returns a promise instead of just a
callback and you say I want video or I
want audio and when you when you get
that you get a stream and with this
stream we can set the source object of a
html5 video element to that stream which
will allow us to preview the video were
recording that what allowed me to see
what we were actually recording but we
can also use a MIDI recorder like this
is supposed to go so we create a new
media recorder pass along that stream
and once we've done this we can start
actually recording the video of our
webcam or the audio of a webcam you can
set some event handlers like what to do
when there's that available or what to
do when you stop recording and then of
course you start recording mmm when this
on that available handler will just fire
every few milliseconds and it will give
you some some data of what has been
recorded which is going to push it into
an array later like so and then when we
start when we stop recording we take
that array and then we convert that to a
blob and then we take that blow-up and
we convert that to some basic C 4
encoded string so we can pass along that
string to a HTML 5 video element it's a
bit of a detour but it works so yeah
that's how you can record video and/or
audio in the browser the next one is my
favorite API of everything if you've
seen my talk at the conference earlier
this year I've talked about this all
talk I will try to keep it short but you
can create audio like so this was not
feedback
it might have sounded like feedback but
you can create order in the browser this
is not like this is not an mp3 file or
the way file this is really all you're
created by the browser it's already a
bit nicer and this is all just created
in a browser by some JavaScript codes
which i think is amazing
it's really an API that I can play
around through it
for hours and hours and never get bored
of it but let's see how you can create
some tones or very very basically the
first thing you need is a new audio
context which is the basis of the Audio
API the Web Audio API once you've got
that you will create an oscillator an
oscillator is just going to create a
tone a fix tone like the first one you
heard the thing that sounded like
feedback but wasn't feedback once you've
got oscillator you can also configure
some values like the frequency or which
type of oscillator should be it should
it be a sine wave or a sawtooth way for
a square wave for stuff like this
and you can start it now when you start
this oscillator you will not hear
anything until you've connected your
oscillator to your destination which is
basically just saying I want to hear the
output of this oscillator through my
speakers it's important to know that the
audio context has a separate clock
because when you're scheduling nodes or
you're making a song you want it to be
very very precise and if you would have
used set interval or set timeouts if
there's stuff happening in your
JavaScript code like some synchronous
codes happening or stuff it will delay
your set interval you don't want that
when you're creating a song so you can
use the separate clock which you can
find under current time like so yeah so
you can just use this time to start and
stop an Australia for example so you
create an oscillator with a certain tone
you start at a certain time stop at a
certain time then create another
oscillator increase the the frequency
started against a bit again that's how
you can compose songs by just starting
and stopping a lot of oscillator
or other stuff so if you put it all
together you create a new audio context
create an oscillator set some frequency
and stuff like this and start it and you
just connect it to your destination
which are your speakers and you can
create music in your browser which is
cool the next one is the vibration API
you can make your phone vibrate using
javascript which is a bit weird but it's
possible and it's very easy but my
laptop cannot fibrate of course so I
can't really show it but if you would go
to this URL later you can try it out for
yourself
if you're using androids and new using
Chrome excuse me I will share it later
with everybody that's okay or you want
to try it now are you on Android and
chrome okay
let's hope this live demo which is not
on my device works
it's me out at some bigger it'll be a
slash vibration example maybe someone
can do a drum roll just an excuse of a
life is going to work no drum roll you
know the URL can I continue or do you
want to see it again so let us know if
it works okay then it just okay and does
it vibrate
anyway it should be very easy to make
your phone if your phone supports the
vibrating API and it should be done like
so you just navigate to the try rate and
you just pass along a time as how long
you want it to vibrate like four hundred
milliseconds you can even like that if I
rate in a pattern like 400 milliseconds
of vibrating 200 if nothing for enough
fire reading and this works really well
if you are on the correct phone using
the correct operating system using the
correct browser and your internet works
very well and who knows what else needs
to be correct but it works I've tried it
true story so the next one is device
orientation and this means that you can
start listening to the orientation of
your device or you can move your device
and get different parameters back so
let's try this out I have this mouse and
my laptop is currently tilted so you see
that the mouse is moving down now if I
would move my laptop a bit like this
you can see the mouse going towards the
cat but we're not cool here so we're not
going to give the cat the mouse or doing
anyway you can start listening for the
orientation of your device and do some
stuff like this like create a fun game
so you could feed your cat Mouse's if
you really wanted to and you can do this
by just listening to a device
orientation event which is just you add
an event listener to your window listen
for a device orientation event and once
this event fires which is a lot if you
have the right hardware in your computer
or phone you'll get back some data like
alpha beta and gamma which have
absolutely no idea what I mean
but if you play play along with it you
will see that they will change based on
how you hold your device it's also
important to know that not every laptop
contains an accelerometer or a gyroscope
for example I also have a 15 inch
version of this laptop and it doesn't
have it and this one does who knows why
it's Apple cessation or whichever
computer and
actually you have but if they have the
right hardware you can start listening
to changes in your device orientation
and create fun games with it for example
so what else is there in the browser we
have the payments API which lets you
just seamlessly integrate with some
native let's call it payment flow so you
can create payments and do payments in a
safe way if the web Bluetooth API which
that you just talked or communicate with
Bluetooth devices if the web USB API
which lets you communicate with USB
devices what I'm trying to say is
there's this many API is coming
constantly into a browser so you really
cannot predict what's coming to the
browser and what I would be able to
detect to tell next year when I would be
at yes
Amsterdam J's for example so it's costly
changing Enders evermore api's being
added to the browser which makes web
development one of the most interesting
fields of computer science in my opinion
but of course we have to chew it all
together
this is the name of my my cats I'm very
original with with cats with names but
you all know that Apple has Siri and
Google has some assistant and then if
Amazon which has Alex I think so I have
pushed and it can do some stuff
I think the audio is turned off on all
my audio is broken doesn't matter it
would talk now because we saw that the
prosecutor but we can ask our stuff like
let's do something fun
I'm never coming back to Holland oh and
dad it so you can listen to the stuff I
say but my cat doesn't know what to do
so let's try this again
yeah let's do something fun AHA and you
can draw ears on your head for example
because snapchat has it an Instagram has
it so you can do stuff like this or say
reminds me what I'm typing one minutes
yeah my computer is very slow it's a 1
minute which is very important so we put
an exclamation mark behind it but it
will hopefully remind me in 1 minutes
you can do stuff like what's the weather
good enough because it knows the word
weather so now it's going to try to get
my location and based on my location is
going to try to fetch me some weather
which is a temperature of seven point
thirty five degrees anybody has a
thermometer no I think I will believe my
cat so if you combine this API so you
can really do some cool experiments on
the web what else can I do because you
have to wait until the minute has passed
of course you can ask what's my battery
status for example what's my battery
status it's fully charged your life
check-check
so we see that something has happened
that reminded us of something very very
interesting but here you can just
combine this api's to do some cool
experiments in the browser that's it you
can find this presentation under me out
at some mega it'll be a and I hope you
liked it or you learn this thing or two
thank you
[Applause]